hey everyone i'm james marsden and i'm
here with buzzfeed today to read your
thirst tweets
james marsden equals best smile in
hollywood
fight me is that a question or an
invitation
james marsden an enchanted is the only
man who deserves rights
he has my heart that is very kind of you
to say you have my heart
i want to lick james marsden's
cheekbones
it's the only safe way to do it now we
got to do it over zoom dead to me on
netflix should be renamed
the 30-minute james marsden sexy
injection how did you know that's the
name of my corporation
accidentally yelled daddy when james
marsden appeared on the tv
in front of my mom nice i hope that
didn't embarrass you too badly
privately maybe your mom was saying the
same thing in her head i need to meet
and mate
with james marsden dm me i think my
bisexual awakening
was james morrison as corny collins in
hairspray maybe mine
too i love that character i bet you
never thought that your bisexual
awakening would come
from a guy named corny i want to get
drunk in a bar with james marsden and
then have sex in the back of his car
hashtag 27 dresses that was 27 dresses
when we when we sang billy the jets on
the bar
and funny story about that that was the
last scene
we ever shot for 27 dresses was the bar
scene it was a night shoot all night
once that scene was finished
the movie was complete catherine and i
were like maybe we should actually have
a tequila shot or two but it was just
enough to make us comfortable but
for the record the the scene in the back
of the car was not that night
the things i would let james marsden do
to me would deny me
entrance to heaven forever i would love
a list of what those things are
because then i might not want to go to
heaven pretty sure james morrison could
ask me to
eat his dirty socks and i would do it
what do you mean pretty sure
you're either sure or you're not sure so
are you sure
that i could give you my dirty socks
when you eat them or are you not sure
james marsden was my sexual awakening a
lot of sexual awakenings i was watching
x2 like i don't know how to do the sex
but i know i want to do it with cyclops
and his strong jawline
i'm very flattered i don't know how to
do the sex either
but what i can do is let you let you
lick the jawline
someone else lick the cheekbones the
jawline is yours i have a feeling that
after all these people hearing me answer
these their awakening is gonna be way
less
sorry babe but the poster of james
marsden as cyclops
stays up during sex thanks for letting
me watch
no offense but i would let james
morrison use me to mop his kitchen floor
and i would achieve orgasm from it you
know there's something for everybody i i
wasn't aware of that fetish but uh
godspeed i know we're all iffy on
westworld this season
but i haven't seen enough discourse
about james marston's butt
which looks like two organic supermarket
eggs cuddling up to each other
thank you this is what i tell my trainer
when i go to the gym every day is i want
my butt cheeks to look like
two eggs cuddling up to each other so
i'm glad i could achieve that
for you james marsden cyclops
james mars in cyclops could have shot
his beams
up my ass and i would have liked it
i'm speechless i want james marsden to
destroy my
bussy every hour i bet he's packing
i'm not sure how to destroy a bussy and
i can't uh i can't comment on the last
statement
glad you all are all about the art thank
you buzzfeed for
um uh embarrassing the hell out of me
check out the stand you all on cbs all
access
coming to you soon
you